good afternoon as Ian said at the
beginning I am Jessica sac not Pam
Frank's and I'm filling in for her today
she's sorry she can't be here I'm going
to be showing a series of images that
illustrate how we teach from the
collections in ways that engage students
in the hopes that cultural heritage and
the arts stay with them during their
entire lives and help them think about
choices they make as they enter the
workforce I'm starting with images of
students who are learning in the
galleries Ian talked a little bit about
courses that are taught in addition to
technical art history and work in
conservation faculty from across the
humanities social sciences and the arts
use the collection both in our general
collection airy and also in our object
study classrooms in addition we work
with Yale students in a variety of ways
we have two groups of students who are
actually trained to teach in the museum
we've undergraduates who work with the
public on chores and we have graduate
students who are taught to train sorry
who are trained to teach school groups
that come to the gallery to learn and in
so doing we are exposing the public to
the range of art from around the world
we tend to teach thematically and
include all collection areas that we
have in the museum in addition these
students are then working with youth in
the community and helping those students
see the broader ways in which art can
help them think about the world around
them in addition to general teaching we
also think a lot here about what it
means to have time based art to be part
of the experience of looking we had an
exhibition of photography by Milt Hinton
and lee friedlander on jazz in which we
had live performance of music happen in
the galleries as a way to think about
how do you hear and see differently how
do you look and listen differently when
you have music and art combined we also
do the same with dance in the slide
there are images to separate dance
programs happening one Trisha Brown and
the other a group called gaga which is
in this case performed by leisure and
Sarah harare who
are who just said to dance a few days
ago in the data exhibition upstairs but
as a way to think about performance in
relationship to the image as well and we
also work with students in exhibition
creation we have students who are
student curators who research who work
with collectors who work with our
curators and our conservators to put on
full size exhibitions in our permanent
galleries and our special exhibition
galleries as a way to think about the
career of a curator but also as a way to
engage really deeply with these objects
so in this slide we have students who
are working with the collector Allen
Chaz knoff whose book collection artist
book collection was given to the gallery
and they put together an exhibition that
was taught from by faculty visited by
the public and was a way for them to
really experience what it means to work
in a museum and really understand and
appreciate what objects can do and sort
of as a way to think about how this all
fits together we're thinking at the
institution here as a teaching museum
about what it means to offer
opportunities for students to think
about cultural heritage and artworks as
resources for learning but in so doing
we're also hoping hoping and I guess the
easiest way to say this is that art
collections are important resources for
higher education which I think we're
agreeing based on the slides that we're
seeing from all these presenters but
also that higher education is an
important resource for art collections
and the future preservation of cultural
heritage as it leads to an appreciation
and understanding that remains with the
students for the rest of their lives and
we're seeing this and the choices that
our students are making as they go on
into careers in the arts and also in
their own sort of dedication to the
preservation of cultural heritage thank
you
you